what's unique about Triathlon is that  everyone have so much knowledge about  training but it just comes down to  execution and quality of training I  think I see myself as uh as a  professional since I was basically 14  years old I was training better than  than some pros do today so I think it's  been a lot of volume high quality  training for many many years that has  made us into the athletes we are today  if you're known for being the ones of  chain the best the ones to train the  most extreme it's kind of like a  positive feedback loop so since  everyone's saying is yeah you're  training the best you're smarter so  scientific you kind of grow into that  even more and that makes you think okay  we have to do everything more have to do  everything more scientific so it's for  sure it's good to be known to be good  because then you thank you uh you're  good yourself so I think it's something  about that as well